how are you and yay
he walked out on snl
like mid monologue
so i haven't talked to him since kim
kardashian revealing kanye west stormed
out of her saturday night live debut i'm
just rolling with it and
it is what it is kim hosted snl back in
october and brought some serious lols
with jokes about her famous family and
her estranged husband i married the best
rapper of all time the richest black man
in america when i divorced him you have
to know it came down to just one thing
his personality well turns out yay
wasn't laughing i'm just extremely happy
can you tell by my face and during the
latest episode of the famous family's
new hulu series kim tells chloe that the
44 year old grammy winner straight up
left just minutes into the show
he's upset of the fact that i said the
reason i divorced him used the word
divorced so he wished i said the word
filed
for divorce when i divorced him you have
to know it came down to just one thing
his personality and he was upset that i
also said he was a rapper he said i'm so
much more than a rapper i can't believe
you said rapper i'm married the best
rapper of all time
i never want to offend anyone and i
never want to hurt anyone but also
that's with this monologue before it was
like to make a joke i made fun of myself
i made fun of my mom i made fun of
everything that's personal to me and
it's all fun and games and apparently it
wasn't to him we kind of knew kanye felt
some kind of way about the jokes though
because back in november he said this on
the drink champs podcast so now making
my wife say i divorced him on tv because
they just wanted to get that bar off and
i ain't never even seen the papers we're
not even divorced
so how we
cause that ain't no joke to me but kim
she's quick to point out the irony in
kanye's upset i've sat there through so
many speeches and things that have not
been the most comfortable for me uh yeah
but that was my partner and i stood by
him i would never embarrass him and walk
not even just speeches
strong public stances he's taken in many
different areas that might not be your
stance but you are his
you were his wife and kim's been saying
this for a while check out what she told
et back in 2018. i've seen him go
through a lot and he's just the most
genuine
person and you know he might say things
that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it but i
always know his heart but i always
believe and trust in him that he will
always eventually explain himself he so
used to getting exactly what he wants
from every person in any category of
life i've never seen anything like good
for him good for him good for him but
hey
it's not gonna happen
here and
not anymore
yeah
we have four kids together i always want
to have a
good healthy relationship with him but
after snl happened i like felt i need to
get new energy well the kkw beauty
founder did just that with her new
boyfriend pete davidson what's your
favorite thing about him he's just super
genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
i love that he's kind
and really really thoughtful he's the
most thoughtful person
and i love yeah and i love the chemistry
that kim and him have together it's
really sweet i thought you said the
chemistry it's like okay chemistry
chemistry
[Music]
you